la deuxième édition de l'événement de
simulation des nations unies de sky moon
a eu lieu mardi 25 mai pour l'occasion
12 étudiants volontaires de l'université
de saint quentin en yvelines sont
devenus des diplomates le temps d'une
journée
chacun s'est vu attribuer un pays et ils
ont choisi une commission en anglais ou
en français
c'est une association étudiante donc du
coup qui regroupe plusieurs étudiants de
l'ens sein de sky news
donc de l'ensemble de l'université et
elle a pour but de mettre la simulation
des nations unies à l'échelle et agent
et qui devront donc du coup des
étudiants qui devront représenter des
délégations pour des sujets très
spécifique qui signifie un peu tous les
pays dont le but de l'association sky
moon permettre aux étudiants de
développer leurs connaissances
politiques et diplomatiques
ils ont débattu et proposer des
solutions sur des problématiques
internationales
ça mettait en place deux comités le
communiqué de l'unicef et de commuter ou
est nécessaire qu'ils représentaient des
problématiques donc le premier comité
c'était sur l'éducation et 2ème trim it
et c'était sur les réfugiés pendant la
période du co lead la journée s'est
terminée sur une réunion de gestion de
crise concernant l' attaque de la bande
de gaza le défi véritable j'ai pas
réussi à lever que représentait avec sa
volonté de convaincre une assemblée
entière d'adopter une certaine position
sur un certain sujet plutôt sujet par
sujet a adopté un ensemble de pros de
l'ensemble des propositions des
étudiants souvent partie avec un
certificat et deux d'entre eux ont été
élus meilleurs délégué